[Música]
y lograr cambiar no es fácil entonces
cuando las señales precursoras se
avecinan hay que darse prisa túnez
durante mucho tiempo país productor de
textiles está a punto de volverse país
creador de moda prueba de ello es la
duodécima edición de la fashion week de
túnez que tuvo lugar no en la capital
sino entonces cerca del desierto pasamos
revista con una selección de tres
diseñadores tunecinos a veces
desconcertantes pero siempre fascinantes
soy head y pvem a mi diseñador de moda e
ingeniero de sistemas de colección está
inspirada en la historia militar ya sea
cartaginés a otomana francesa y también
se trata de una oda a la liberación
durante la pandemia la dificultad más
grande es el abastecimiento
sobre todo con el cubil justamente no
contamos con importaciones
ellos nos incitó a usar materiales
locales ya sea la fibra vegetal o el
algodón
trabajé incluso un material que se llama
hormigón es hormigón que parece cuero es
una innovación que hice y sustituye el
cuero y
la moda es un asunto de tecnicidad es
pero también de mensajes por comunicar
la noche se ame esas políticas que
hicimos habiendo nacido sino la
colección ya la moda de su mensaje
político porque tal como pude ver la
colección hay looks a través de los
cuales me burlé incluso de la fanfarria
de los políticos y de la clase dirigente
aunque se nota que en especial con las
piezas extravagantes las pecheras
extravagante se demoran cutty sark
angustia y moviecity hay un lado
humorístico mucho humor y al mismo
tiempo es un poco burlón de hecho
[Música]
seif ten la uitice se define como
mestizo mitad tunecino mitad taiwanés y
basó su colección en un concepto
estudiado en psicología social la
reactivación como mantener su libertad
de actuar cuando se crea amenazada
zanjado
gates mi colección esta noche fue del
tipo saber por qué
entonces atacó la censura y el sexo y se
dirige a una especie de gen zeta que no
quiere sucumbir a esta norma de la
sociedad que le ha dictado a la gente
mayor que yo y de mi edad y que viene
atrás hayek como x una monada y xx
[Música]
siendo honesto usted debe tener un
mensaje de lo contrario solo desperdicia
más hay que tener una colección y una
historia un concepto con un mensaje
tratamos de regenerar el planeta de
salvarlo entonces si hay un mensaje o es
inútil
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a nuestros ojos para el nuevo uso
siempre ha hecho parte de la marca
narcís
pero ahora es un ejercicio de estilos
un ejercicio de imaginación
un ejercicio de género
ok tengo esto y hago esto desde 2012
tengo mucho
lo he hecho mucho pero ahora qué puedo
hacer con lo que tengo para uno de lo
nuevo
mejore lo no trate de obtener nuevas
cosas no sume desde el planeta entonces
por favor recicla aplicó cycle
brain que no tiene 30 años aún pero
ejerce las artes plásticas desde
temprana edad sostiene una relación de
odio y amor con la moda desarrollo
naturalmente en la noción anti fashion
tanto
si vine cuando aún tenía 20 años o 21
era pequeño incógnito en este mundo
porque en general el medio de la moda en
túnez son amigos que estuvieron juntos
en el liceo
yo vine de ningún lado
tuve mi primer desfile en el 2015 primer
desfile primera aparición con live con
ideación en parís con llama moto rick
owens elie saab en el mismo editorial no
conoce a nadie hice contactos conocí
gente y eso fuentes
[Música]
tomando el dl conceptual mi moda es
conceptual architectural poética pero al
mismo tiempo hardcore
como fundición y latín y el américa tuvo
mi proveedor es tunecino pero trae casi
todo todo su material lo trae de
guangzhou tengo incluso telas 3d no está
mal con respecto a lo que hay aquí
incluso en parís es complicado
entonces si uno de los que se
desenvuelve se desenvuelve en túnez
júpiter parís o haga vudú es lo mismo
es la sexta participación de bryan clay
en la fashion week de túnez y nunca ha
cambiado de discurso fer de shows
universal yo quiero hacer cosas
universales que no tengan nacionalidad
no puedes ponerlo en un marco y
encerrarlo soy libre zuiker cando jeep
que vive en mami chef en la wiki bryan
clay tres diseñadoras que reivindican
una misma libertad de tono y expresión
para hacer ingresar a túnez en el diseño
[Música]